let's talk about guerrilla games as
horizon zero dawn I feel like every time
they showed this game I'm more and more
impressed by it Alexa what did you think
I'm really like that you can hack the
correct the creatures not like sort of
use them make a mount um we got a little
bit more of the story I think she was
talking about corrupted and like
machines being older and like not
knowing where it came from I'm really
into like you said earlier I'm really
into the idea of a different post
apocalypse where I like machinery and
that kind of stuff still exists and it
has overrun us all so those are rabbit
so there are animals yes good real
aminal importance that there are still
on minnows and yes you are [ __ ] bad
animal robot animals to make dance and
also just straight up like stealing
components out of these dumb dumpster
truck robots Peter what did you think
I'll horizon zero dawn when it comes to
stealing components that was the thing
they should last year and I really like
that concept but one thing that has me
worried about this game is the fact that
it seems to be relying so heavily on the
juxtaposition of two very different eras
and and I'm just I don't want that to be
the thing that is supposed to make this
game interesting because on the like for
me just that alone doesn't do it right I
need to I need to know how these
characters are interacting what role
they play and all of that the action
looks great you know like I could see
that being fun and interesting and
challenging and certainly dynamic in a
lot of interesting ways but in terms of
the world I'm just not sold yet right
one of the things I was very impressed
by and they stood sort of show last year
with that big t-rex style fight was the
boss fights and how you need to sort of
actually use some smarts to overcome
them right Ezrin what did you think
about the the fight in this one she was
kind of like using Flame arrows and then
yeah planting traps and stuff I really
like how they gave you options so you
could tackle a battle in whatever like
strategic way you wanted I like shooting
like the ropes to tie the thing down
right you know that was one way to
delimit the movement of the monster and
I just thought it was a really cool way
of them like explaining how to do
certain things in the world right so for
example like taming that beast to ride
it like it some games have you know you
get to tame horses you can steam this
you get to have mounts there was you
know you're taking over a robotic mind
like it becomes your your friendly mount
and I thought
that was like a really cool way to
approach a mechanic that we've seen
before but in a very different way I
love the fact that you could then it you
know use that within the boss fight as
well I wasn't accepting ok here we are
boss fight let's go like this does feel
like it feels like they're trying to
make an open world game with all these
different systems that interact with
each other and which you could argue
they never did what kill zone because
almost a straight up first person
shooter and the you know there wasn't
much in a way of you know dynamic
gameplay or emergent gameplay happen and
anything like that but there seems to be
like little bits of that were there at
least like giving you the sort of
sandbox saying this is how it works got
crafting so he has to be open world yeah
for sure not serious like I don't think
you have a game with crafting that's not
open world right looks pretty as well
man that rope gun look at that hair
looks awesome I'm just yeah Harry water
mostly really noticeable during that
fight yeah I was five pack that robot
thing on tennis with fully enjoy yeah
look at that she's USB in my tricks head
alright that's horizon zero dawn very
exciting i feel like people are still
super hyped about that when is this
actually coming out this is one of the
ones i did for 328 2017 very good oh my
god perfect are perfectly done yeah okay
just two weeks after valentine's day
poof there you go